all right the match-up draft for week 15
and chris i have the trivia question if
you get it right you get the first pick
if you get it wrong i get the first pick
lamar jackson has 28 passing touchdowns
this year he is only six touchdown
passes away from breaking the ravens
single season record who holds that
record
now and i'll give you a clue he wasn't
drafted by the ravens
all right so wait we're talking about td
passes right we're talking about td
players for the ravens yes who holds the
record of 34 touchdown passes for the
ravens and he wasn't drafted by the
ravens gosh uh i i guess i'm going to go
with steve mcnair there i don't know
darn it
oh
it was vinnie's testimony oh mike man
then he had a year where he had 36
touchdown passes on the ravens damn i
didn't really 33 33 33
yeah 33's the record lamar is six away
from setting it five from tying it in
the first season of the ravens 1996 many
tests have already had 33 touchdown
passes so the mark has stood ever since
then all right i get the first pick and
uh where am i gonna go first pick first
pick first pick let me go with the game
in dallas with significant playoff
implications wade phillips who was fired
by the cowboys running the defense
for the rams against jason garrett who
is on the verge of getting fired
suffering the same fate that wade
phillips faced nine years ago when
garrett was there on the staff remember
all the controversy about jason garrett
making more money than wade phillips
that was the thing at one point right
garrett gets the job phillips gets the
pink slip and phillips now coordinating
the rams defense and he can put another
nail in that jason garrett coaching
coffin if the rams can stymie dak
prescott ezekiel elliott and company so
that's going to be a fun one of because
of that subplot and i'm sure wade
phillips would even though he would
never say it
he would love to stick it to jerry jones
jason garrett and the entire cowboys
organization yeah i don't disagree with
you there at all a hundred percent and
you know you got to stick it to them in
the playoffs last year and you know wade
phillips that defense is rolling right
now again they've really corrected
themselves since that baltimore ravens
game and uh that you're right that's
personal i'm gonna go personal too a
little bit a game though it's not like
necessarily a huge game this weekend but
uh how about kyle shanahan versus his
old team the atlanta falcons and dan
quinn and company you think he's going
to want to like show them who's boss i
do you know and again i haven't talked
to kyle in a long time so this has
nothing to do with him but you know just
the way it all ended for shanahan in
atlanta where
people blamed him for the management of
the super bowl i didn't know he was the
head coach at the time and i feel like
matt ryan and dan quinn kind of let it
like everybody just like oh yeah it was
kyle's fault right we did nothing wrong
he's not here anymore we don't have to
worry about it you know that was a bs
move by both of them and i would think
kyle shanahan knowing the competitor he
is he wants to stick it to the atlanta
falcons this week and i wouldn't be
shocked if they were up by 40 in the
fourth quarter and he wanted to score
one more to make sure they're up by 50
something that that's to me now no no i
think the goal should be to land the
final score on 28 to 3. that's what i
think
that would be really good well well
played florio
all right i'm gonna go with something
that a week ago we would have just
scoffed at but because of what happened
on sunday in cleveland
all of a sudden zach taylor versus bill
belichick whoa significant match-up
right because bill belichick is going to
try to try to cram it up the wrong way
sideways on zach taylor in the bengals
they will be on to cincinnati and they
will be all over cincinnati and they
will not let up i and and it's just
look
nobody expects the bengals to keep it
close from a football standpoint it's
not a compelling game but because of
this whole spy gate 2 thing and the
reports that the bengals are livid and
the way the bengals set it all up it was
kind of cute in the press conference the
radio color commentator
asked the question to kind of plant the
idea so taylor could talk about it and
they could inject it into the media that
way belichick is pissed about this whole
thing and i suspect he's mad at zach
taylor for dealing with it the way that
he did and he's going to have something
for zach taylor and company when the
game rolls around on sunday and and hey
if nothing else a game that otherwise
would have been a road apple is
compelling because of everything that's
happened this week yeah how quickly is
that handshake going to happen after the
game i mean it's going to be like the
old walk by where bill just puts his
hands out never really stops hey whoa
see you later good game
keep going so yeah you're right i didn't
really think about that one but there's
definitely a little added incentive into
that game
what if what if we see what if we see a
moment where belichick like pulls him in
and dresses him down
i you know and you can see he's talking
to him and you can say what he's saying
to him you know like that that was yeah
what if we what if the lip reader
brigade brigade can see that he's saying
that was bull something that you what
you guys did i mean who knows but i
think that the cameras should be on
those two guys as they uh as they meet
at the uh you know at the midfield after
the game yeah i i i hear that i i think
if bill was to do it he'd probably say
it before the game if he wanted to do it
so i hope they keep the cameras on them
in pregame if they have a little you
know maybe
i could see bill want to make a point
though he wants none of this to stick to
him yeah this is the equivalent of if
you're innocent of something you shout
it from the rooftops this is him
shouting from the rooftops if we can see
him plainly see that was really some
bull bleep that you pulled this week i'm
going to be very intrigued by that that
that final few seconds before they go
off air from patriots bengals where new
england wins 38 to 2 it'll be
interesting to see what happens yeah
definitely um i'm going to go to our
game on sunday night football
uh on the the bit you know and i know
this is boring but hey this is where
games are won okay i know this isn't
always the sexiest but the bill's o-line
versus the steelers front i mean that's
the key to the game to me it really is i
mean we saw the bills last week josh
allen woke up monday morning last week
against the baltimore ravens it's the
source guy in the nfl he got bludgeoned
i mean they killed him they hit him in
every part of his body over and over
again the steelers are probably a better
pa are they are a better pass rushing
team than the baltimore ravens and do
all the creative things to go along with
it so the bill's front offensive line is
going to have to be on its game i think
the bills can really win this game on
sunday night as long as they don't have
a strip sack fumble or josh allen as
he's throwing gets hit and blindsided
the ball pops in the air and becomes an
interception something like that because
they're both great defenses you know i
would argue that the bill's offense is a
little is better of course than the
steelers offense but the big thing will
be that the steelers can make so many
big plays with just the ferociousness
and creativity of their defense to where
i think it really could come to
bud dupree and tj watt make a strip sack
fumble or cause a turnover that way it
could be the difference of the game
there's a dangerous game looming for the
vikings in la against the chargers the
packers go out there and get splattered
a few weeks ago yep and that vikings
offensive line which danielle hunter the
defensive lineman who was the nfc's
defensive player of the week had three
sacks last week he told me after the
game the offensive line is the reason
why the vikings offense is so much
better this year it's going to be
everything they can handle with melvin
ingram and joey bosa and can they buy
enough time
for kirk cousins to throw the ball can
they open the holes for dalvin cook you
know cook still pops up on the injury
report with a chest problem he was fine
last week against the lions but
alexander madison his backup didn't
practice on wednesday with an ankle
problem so they need cook to be able to
be effective and
yeah he he may have to carry more of the
load and that defensive line and that
defense is swarming and they're
effective and this chargers team is
better than five and eight would suggest
yes they just destroyed the jaguars on
sunday and it won't surprise me if the
vikings walk into a buzz saw when they
go out there to play this week scary
scary matchup for the your minnesota
vikings very scary very for your
minnesota vikings i mean the chargers
are the fourth best defense in football
they're legit they can rush the passer
they're good in the they're good in past
defense and what also scary is i mean as
long as philip rivers doesn't like throw
stupid interceptions you know they
should be able to throw the ball in your
vikings defense that is scary i like
that you're you're right that's a good
one all right i'm gonna go with what we
did here to kick off this segment i mean
i i am excited to see baker mayfield
versus kyla murray i mean come on i
gotta take it i mean if it's there for
the last pick i'm going to take it it's
the past two heisman winners
against each other and i know they're
not on the field at the same time but
still they're gonna be like paying
attention to what the other one's doing
on the field you have a personal
competitive nature against the other
quarterback you're playing against
that's a very real thing so you know not
only are they the past two heisman
winners they were at the same school
together kyla murray was baking uh
backing up baker mayfield and i think
that is going to be one where they are
you know they're they're going to be
invested into i want to one up the other
guy to show that i am the better boomer
sooner that way uh it's killing me that
i'm a texas longhorn and i'm talking
about the damn oklahoma sooners but uh
that is a special special football
program it's really one of the best
there is in all of college football
and the other angle to this one is the
cliff kings
mayfield
from past years right where where
mayfield transferred to oklahoma patrick
mahomes took over at quarterback and
both kingsbury and mayfield saying all
the right things now and and i think
mayfield means it where he says that was
a long time ago i don't really care if
he cared he'd say so yeah you wouldn't
hold that back so uh that's another
wrinkle on this one and it would be it
would be better if you know the
cardinals were a better team but they
they look they gave the steelers uh
everything they can handle last week
they may do the same thing with the
browns all right we're going to take a
break we'll return more on the thursday
night game
uh with some predictions some prop bets
and whatnot meanwhile before we go our
picks for the most important matchups of
week 15. i've got wade phillips versus
jason garrett bill belichick versus zach
taylor the vikings o-line versus the
chargers d-line sims has dan quinn
versus kyle shanahan the bill's o-line
versus the steelers run seven and baker
mayfield versus kyler
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports